I just dropped the mic probably earlier
than I should have in this video yes I
get that but bear with me ready with
grace so it's ready with grace because i
really don't want to write this whole
thing by myself it's riding with grace
riding with me me my name is grace
welcome to the second to last chapter
reveal of writing with brace a series it
doesn't sound this dramatic out loud as
it did in my head but still very
exciting now let's get to some
statistics wow you might have noticed my
amazing mic drop in the beginning of
this video if you didn't what we're
doing that was because this week in your
submissions forty-six percent of you
included an air mic drop which is great
air Mike dropping is an actual art form
very easily you can be dropping
something else I'll just give you a
quick demonstration today and if you
want to try and guess what I'm dropping
in all of these scenarios bobby pin 11
golf balls 12 go my childhood ghost that
was also microphone have you learned
nothing seventy-five percent of you
included rain as part of your freak week
day 7 event Wow a lot of you watch music
videos and I guess want some sort of
cleansing process to happen at the end
of this freak week more than one of you
had said in your submission that rap is
the truest form of expressing emotion
rap i can say has had a very
transformative effect on me from when i
was a young child I remember listening
to the rap beans beans the magical fruit
the more you eat the more you know I
won't say the end of it for legal
purposes but it rhymes with your pants
thirty percent of you guys we're very
offended by the fact that I said bobby
pins cannot open locks and you argued
that a real locksmith commented on the
subject letting us know that bobby pins
do in fact work so okay great I'm wrong
I'm wrong bro progress grace now on to
some superlative
this week's Award for Best talking goes
to it's a tie first for wintry garnet
went regarding called out in their
dialogue that lace hates rhyming lace
blink back to sleep in her eyes I hear
what you say but what could you possibly
have today dogs music truth quakes and
no gravity then it gets worse with the
lights and candy haven't you already
noticed my perfect crime it's your
personal pet peeve lace rhyme what a
cool call back good job went to a garnet
also wintery garnet has been
participating and submitting a chapter
every single week of writing with grace
so thank you so much for your consistent
support and participation I give you
this moment our other winner this week
for best dialogue goes to Alex Fowler 84
mr. Kevin's in-depth analysis of the rap
battle you guys banana totally crush
that last bit and their team could
really win marmi whispers at the slight
tension in her voice but our team
produced straight consistent fire
throughout the battle whereas the
opposing team were a bit inconsistent
with their fire it was more like a
landslide but instead of sliding down it
slides up mr. Kevin raisins that was
amazing also who knew mr. Kevin so in
touch with the youth speech known to
best prize the prize the winner is and
the LH 2001 henna LH 2001 gave us an
insight into mr. Kevin that none of us
knew before mr. kevin's full name is
Kevin Kevin Harry you don't say the
claps people do them says mr. Kevin
literally looking down on Harry sorry
sir please call me Kevin your first and
last name is Kevin sir yes it is I love
that so much it's so simple and so
beautiful you get such an insight into
the anguish she's experienced in his
life was thank you for that and now they
weren't for prompt fries
athletic aesthetic for deciding that day
seven of freak week turns our cast of
characters into famous and
world-renowned paintings mr. Kevin
becomes mr. Mona Lisa Oh excellent
opportunity for spinoff series I want to
know everything about mr. Kevin and then
we'll to our choice chapter for this
week our choice for chapter 7 goes to
roses and somewhere freezer chapter
break it down and I'm gonna break down
why I love this chapter 1 there's the
drama that freak week might become freak
forever Lester who has crushes older
evil brother once freak week to continue
on into infinity time dangerous also all
the events from previous days of freak
week happen back to back to back to back
to back there are [ __ ] zoos in the sky
there are truth quakes happening all the
way find out that crushes real name is
Bob and then they have this rap battle
that happens which is actually very
impressive and we find out that crush is
actually really bad at rapping he has an
Achilles heel and it's wrapping and
Kevin Kevin Kevin mr. Kevin actually
calls it out which is really hilarious
group ends up forgiving banana for
joining Lester's evil side and then Jim
speaks up and lets everyone know that
Lester's calculations are wrong and it's
not that freak week is gonna continue
forever instead because these
calculations are wrong the world is
going to blow up this could be the end
because of Lester's terrible terrible
calculations molecules are getting mixed
up from the freak week satellites and so
someone has to go and shut down the
satellites Lester decides to risk his
own life to try and save everyone out
but then the chapter ends in silence
there's a big eruption of no one knows
where Lester is everyone seems to be
alive we don't know this is basically
the physical representation of where the
chapter ends it ends like this what
that's where we are in chapter 8 is up
to me so we don't have any prompts for
you this week because it's it's my turn
you know I'm gonna be writing so much
about mr. Kevin it's gonna be but what I
do need actually and really would love
is your thoughts on how you think this
whole novella should end how should
freak week be wrapped up what should
happen in Chapter eight you won't get
chapter eight until vid cuff likes
surprise we're gonna be releasing
chapter 81
read the entire novella out loud don't
worry it's gonna be filmed so it'll be
up on this channel for those of you that
aren't able to see the library next week
there will be another episode of riding
with grace be more of an overall roundup
and catch up about the whole writing
with grace process you want to catch up
on freak week as it is now go to wattpad
calm / writing wit oh yeah thank you
guys so much for submitting to this
whole process you guys are very very
talented writing a rap battle it's not
easy Oh many of you gave us wonderful
submissions that this might have been
the hardest week to choose so congrats
on making things difficult I'll see you
guys on there and let every day all day
I don't know
[Music]